en Ukraine la ville Dodé sa cible de
frappe russe la nuit dernière selon Kiev
4 missiles de croisière se sont abattus
sur des bâtiments civils trois personnes
ont été tuées la correspondance de
Gulliver crack à Kiev
ce n'est pas beaucoup d'informations
mais il semblerait qu'au moins trois
personnes sont morts et les services de
sauvetage sont toujours sur place il se
peut que d'autres se trouvent dans les
décombres d'après les images que je vois
c'est un immeuble partiellement
résidentiel et partiellement au centre
commercial qui a été touché non loin du
centre-ville les autorités sur place
disent aussi que beaucoup de voitures
ont été détruits comme c'est souvent le
cas en fait avec ces frappes c'était des
requêtes de type calibre qui ont frappé
au dessin ce matin
une autre série de frappa à viser cette
fois la région orientale de d'aonesse 3
civils ont péri dans le même temps le
président Zelinski a revendiqué des
avancées sur le terrain et il a remercié
les soldats je vous propose de l'écouter
dont le secteur de darkmouth grâce au
soldats de la 80ème brigade d'assaut
aérien il y a un mouvement vers l'avant
dans plusieurs zones je vous remercie
merci pour votre bravo extraordinaire
aux divisions tavrilla dans le sud vous
prenez part à des combats féroces ou la
saillant à l'avantage au sol et dans les
airs là aussi il y a un mouvement vers
l'avant merci aux soldats